bum bum bum ba da nananana Donna
welcome to Hockey Night in Canada no
wait wait wait wait wait this isn't
hockey night this is the Harlan Highway
podcast is what it is
thank you very much I'm sorry for that
false intro gang
there's nothing false about today's show
oh my god talk about podcast royalty my
special guest today's with me the whole
show you could call him the king of
podcasts um this gentleman has probably
had the number one podcast with the most
listeners the most followers the most
fans out of any other podcast out there
there might be a few that come close
three or four but this this this
gentleman's been in the lead for many
many years he was one of the original
pioneers of podcasting mr. Adam Carolla
is my special guest today Adam is at the
top of the podcast field
I am honored to have him as a guest on
my show today we're gonna be talking
about all kinds of things we're gonna be
playing too soon or not too soon towards
the end of the show we're gonna cover a
whole range of topics Adams gonna tell
us if he believes in heaven or hell and
oh man it did just listen
Adams a guy that has a deep wealth of
knowledge and he's gonna share it with
us today here on the Heartland highway
you just made a wrong turn onto the
heartland
what's wrong with everybody in this
crazy place the Harland Highway opening
to what to another dimension of this is
Harland Williams everybody this is
Harland Williams you are rolling down
the Harland Highway and holy sweet
Louisiana crab gumbo what a treat we
have today
sweet and sour treat my special guest
today you know him from Adam Carolla
dot-com you know I'm from his his movies
his documentaries his TV shows the one
and only ace aka Adam Carolla is on the
Harlan Highway did a hit body man how
are you what's up ah it's good busy you
know it's in life this is the earliest
I've ever seen you in the morning like I
think your eyes are still puffy um like
an owl
yeah I go to bed with them puffy I wake
up the puffy and then midday the puffy
as well so I'm pretty puffed out most
days I I I got up early this morning do
some radio following so you've already
done so so your voice is like your voice
is ready to go yeah it is it is a funny
thing though do you ever do you ever do
that thing where you stay up late and
then you get up early and then you sit
down and then you call into the radio
station and at 6:30 in the morning you
realize you haven't spoken and you're up
all night you know smoking crack and
drink it out of a flask and doing rails
off a hookers ass it's true it says
flask anymore get up in the morning get
up and you start talking to boomer and
floor wax yeah nothing saw and Eddie
nothing's coming out of your mouth I
know it's hot you still got Hmong mouth
right yeah Myung mouth you're all puffy
your pops cream before we get going or
anything
I don't own a puffin from the Arctic
Circle I don't know
gay slang yes the answer all right here
we go so we're gonna talk to Adam today
and you know I wanted to get into some
some cool stuff because you know you
always have a deep perception of
everything and I thought maybe I would
ask you like what does heaven look like
like when you get up there is there like
7-elevens as their tennis clubs where do
people sleep where do people go to the
bathroom like what the hell
everyone thinks we dime do we just float
around like what's up there guy tell me
well for me is an atheist nothing oh
you're an atheist yeah but nothing
actually these days is actually kind of
a good I'm looking forward to nothing
really so hard yeah I got a lot of
something going on in my life all the
time and I'm sort of looking forward to
nothing wait if your kid comes up to you
and goes daddy which heaven look like
you just say nothing to your kid I'll
say I'll tell you what daddy's gonna
take a nap I want you to quietly take
shoes off sneak in this room in about 20
minutes
and then when you see me doing that's
what are you puffy when you do it no I
lie to my kids and you know tell them
that my dog Molly who we put down for
months
went over the Rainbow Bridge you know
that hold the whole night your dog was
gay yeah that's yeah I'm saying wait a
minute dude okay cut but where did you
where did things go wrong that you don't
believe in in an afternoon God it sounds
you don't you're an atheist when did
this happen I grew up in a world filled
with nothing yeah
with people who had nothing preached
nothing discussed nothing and just it
was never part of my upbringing and at
any level with anybody in my sphere and
there wasn't much of a sphere going on
at the Corolla house it was a very
limited sphere have you ever prayed no
have you ever felt a connection to a
greater bigger force than you just Jimmy
who's Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel
Jimmy's your god no it's just that's the
connection to the greater force
I don't get connected to them have you
been out nature haven't you like no I
travel and one of those Habitrail
hamster globes that was uh yes I've
convened with nature I'd see that's I
think that you might not know it mr.
Corolla but I think that's connecting to
God you might have might have missed it
but you have I I got a I got a dog I got
a black lab the black lab is about six
months old and I took fill the black lab
or Philly cheesesteak Holland's like
that's a good name for him when he gets
hit and he's roadkill ya know yeah and
what happens trip provolone I took I
took him to Malibu and I let him hit the
beach for the first time ever last
weekend and he's a water dog and he went
berserk that was having he I was heaven
yeah he was chasing seagulls he was
diving into the water he was running out
digging holes idle pools you know and
that to me when I sort of would just
watch this dog sort of go berserk yeah
for the first time the dog had seen the
ocean and it was in any such a crazy
water dog that like when my daughter
takes a shower he'll just jump into the
shower
where's what does he do her hair and
stuff does he wash her hair he'll give
her like rinse and a repeat a cuticle
push and all the talk about boys and
don't wonder if they do fart bubbles
well not in the shower but that's your
dog you probably if you're a water dog
you probably have a specialized dog
[ __ ] and you can do water bubbles
standing up well I don't I'm not Cesar
Millan but the dog whisperer
yeah I think your audience is quite
familiar with you Cesar Millan it I know
it sounds like a salad yeah I'll have
the Cesar Millan please with cheese
sauce I do think as we start melting
everything together in 50 years when we
bring up Cesar Millan's name it's gonna
be like he played the Joker in the
original no that's right Riddler who was
that guy ya know
not Cesar Millan that's what I'm here to
tell you yeah yeah and I don't have a
crystal ball
I would love Cesar Millan to just shout
at a dog just like scream like the dog
whisperer just loses it yeah screams at
the top of his lungs and the dog just
blows up don't you you ever listen you
ever listen to those Saturday morning
pet shows on AM radio I and they say let
us somebody but whatever the fix is for
the dog yeah like you call the expert no
and it's way more trouble then like the
experts supposed to give you a tip yeah
like so they'll do this thing where
they're like hi listen I in the calling
war next time yeah I'll call Warren I
will see a Nazi war criminal he fled
okay to Brazil or next okay and they'll
say Warren I have a Schnauzer and my
schnauzer will nip at some of the
neighbors and can pull a little bit Adam
it's a little bit aggressive with some
of the neighbors dogs and some of the
neighbors and I take him for a walk
every day and I'm scared he's gonna bite
one of the neighbors how do we remedy
this problem and Warren will be like
well have you thrown a party for the dog
and it'll go by the way the answer is no
unless I'm criminally insane what you
should do is you should throw a party
for the dog you should invite all the
neighbors you know have them all bring a
gift a tree on offering the dot and it's
like this is a yes this would remedy
this problem except for it's never gonna
happen on [ __ ] planet Earth
that's like idiots who wrap presents for
their dogs of Christmas and think the
dogs gonna take its little hands and
delicately unwrap the Christmas present
no it's like saying my ex my son is not
doing well in math no okay well why
don't you pay an Asian tutor to work
with him seven hours a day like that's
not really a tip no I'd like to lose
some weight all right we'll do nothing
but drink stream water and do push-ups
like oh that's not a tip speaking of
losing weight is it is it just me
as is Marie Osmond like looking for it
you've seen her on these deeds on
nutrasweet commercials or whatever like
everyone they did you want have you seen
her Nutrisystem new to her yeah every
commercial she just gets like trampy or
entrelac Jesus now she looks like a like
a ac/dc groupie she's like are you
chubby do you like to go to the backroom
and plow the drummer from it she's just
like getting trampy I had not noticed so
hot I don't know Marie well you will I'm
very good friends with Jimmy Osmond
however you are very close how bigger is
teeth like how fast could he buzz
through a cedar tree oh that's an unfair
depiction of huge teeth the Osmonds of
giant teeth yeah I guess they were fish
they'd be parrot fish I'm not trying to
insult your friend well it's a little
late well I didn't give him the big
teeth sir I gotta tell you yes he might
come over here and pretend to play the
trumpet in front of you like he's to do
back in the dineymarie show back in the
day I saw that my first concert is a
little boy ever was the Osmonds really I
sawed Donny Osmond and they brought
Little Jimmy out he was like the bonus
treat I think he was still like in a
cradle or something he pretend to play
the trumpet ah I'm straight uh now I
want to tell you I can relate to your
thing on the beach with the dogs
because I had at first time I took my
dogs to the beach it was wonderous yeah
what you're saying it like it was to see
ain't an animal that never would have
got to the beach if it lived in the wild
because it was a dog and and my dog was
anti water I had this really rare breed
called a Jindo and they're very cat-like
and my dog would not even step on the
grass in the morning if there was do on
it uh-huh
and even the magic of the ocean he ran
she ran into the ocean like it was such
an enchanting moment to see why and the
glistening sand and your dogs running
and getting excited by the I think
you're right that is heaven a dog seeing
the beach and the ocean for the first
time is heaven you did have the answers
probably and the answer probably graced
more
greeting cards than any other image the
dog on the beach for the well for the
first time not sure if we pop the sand
Hyman on the dog whoops but what I'm
saying have you ever done doggy style on
a beach that's interesting I mean that's
that kind of a dog question no but next
time I bring Phil out there I'll
definitely live in a world I'll have to
explain to my wife whose idea this one I
didn't want to disrespect Ireland by not
obeying is very strict wishes good Lord
whatever you ask you this yeah if you
don't if you don't think there's a
heaven sad there's a hell that is heaven
we found sea I said at the beginning
Adam would have the answer and you did
yes that is that dogs on the beach for
the first time experiencing the ocean I
totally agree yes and it should be a
nice five and a half month old lab
that's just going berserk in the water
yeah not that he'll look like the halls
down there I worked at a decorative box
Factory in gardena I was doing a remodel
of it back when I was a carpenter but
the decorative box decorative box well
you know when you buy like your estee
lauder products I just picture pink with
Christmas tinsel on her Brazilian yeah
that's a decorative box
come on was that what you mean no I'm
saying like a floral arrangement yeah
like a bob you worked in floral you
worked in the flower industry now please
listen okay this is our important skill
to have I not get your sake Vox yes I
worked as a carpenter yes doing a
remodel okay got a tenant improvement is
what they called it of offices that were
in a decorative box factor I needed to
listen there and I didn't and then he's
alright roped me in and I'm here I got a
kit drauf your Fanta
recalibrate okay got it but even though
you said all that I'm still picturing
Pink's Brazilian with Christmas tinsel
oh sorry there that was the only good
part about the factory - so this was
held to you is at your point well as I
went out to this you know ten thousand
square-foot facility and I walked into
the back and I saw these poor husky
Guatemalan middle-aged oh no life in
their eyes whoa putting together these
decorative boxes that they would never
receive dude you should take those
Guatemalan women and set them free on
the beach I should take him to the beach
yeah yeah anyways go ahead I'm listening
as I gazed out upon the super
downtrodden women who are ironically
putting together these super nice boxes
our rich guys to buy their goomahs you
know what I'm such a good Maz
it sounds like an art project italian
for girlfriend on the side oh i pictured
some mother saying Billy finish your
goombazz and we can show it to Daddy
when you get home deck that's that's
possible okay not that that phrase has
never been honored but guma Kumar you
have you ever watched like The Sopranos
no you gotta have the GU MA on the side
okay but either way he'll to me you know
this city of Gardena which is horrific
and then working in a decorative box
Factory yeah in the city of Gardena
while these poor women just sort of sat
so that waiting to die that's hell on
earth but do you believe in kind of that
metaphysical hell where there's fire and
brimstone and tortured souls and I mean
is that is that a real thing in your
mind or like I don't know no I know I
don't I don't believe in that I also
don't I feel like fire and brimstone or
redundant yeah cuz they're almost the
same if you had fire you got brimstone
if you got brimstone you got fire we
don't need that and this what about have
you ever been to a Kenny Rogers roasters
yeah is that in there too like fire
brimstone and Kenny Rogers roasters well
I'd have to see it depends I can't
remember how they do their potatoes
I don't like thick cut potatoes
like the tunneling wedge potatoes and so
for me that would be hell because I like
a nice thin fry yeah old school you know
McDonald style
have you ever oh yeah Kurt you like
curly fries i i like curly fries but i I
find them unnecessary yeah like I feel
like I've never eaten a McDonald's
french fry and says why isn't this thing
springing back at me and shooting
ketchup into my cornea you know what I
mean like I've never really said Weiser
there's not enough give to these fries I
can't unfurl them and push them back
into shape I think they put hairspray on
them to keep them curl like is there
someone back there in the kitchen with
that was on a curling iron like doing
them by hand I'll tell you what we hand
curl our own curly fries here at Arby's
I'll give you the answer tomorrow
tomorrow I love you tomorrow you're
always a day where's heaven right yeah
keep singing yeah I got a blue Annie
inspired the curl you just sent me to
heaven what about it you know you know
construction you've heard of a blast
furnace mm-hmm I did a show like a few
months back and I asked a guy what he
did for a living and he goes I work in a
blast furnace mm-hmm and I go I said I
go how are you even alive dude and then
I said yeah you're the only guy that
will ever go to hell and go yeah so
right what is a blast furnace tell this
crowd that's listening cuz if anyone
knows how to describe a blast furnace
it's Adam Zachary Corolla right that's
me I miss my years doing that Tim Allen
show what is a blast furnace
home-improvement well first off I don't
think anyone works in a blast furnace
this guy did apparently work around what
is it run of one what is it it's a
furnace that they use for what tell us
it's for smelting today ah smelter fish
it's melts or what you do to steel and
other ores really then you pour them
into shapes and you make eye beams and
trusts and things like of like raw metal
into a blast furnace and it melts it
into a liquid
form is that what you're trying to tell
the audience I think you put the raw
like ingots in get so it's like a juicer
for yeah you're gonna like seeding it if
you're gonna smelt an ingot wasn't ingot
of bobsled champion in the 76 Olympics
final downhill yeah but yes so your
internal impact you put the ingots yeah
and the ones inside you you you smelt an
ingot
oh I haven't smelt an ingot no long yeah
well you listen well that's my version
of heaven Oh sniffing an ingot you know
we don't talk metallurgy enough I know
blast furnace man that's enough for that
I'm moving on okay well you want to just
limit it to no like minutes of that well
I have a lot of questions for you I want
to get into a quick it because those
were long excellent answers you you what
you win already this one's just a yes or
no answer answer mm-hmm
let me see where is it oh here we go
let's see yes or no answer you don't
even have to go into it okay you
probably will do priests take their
callers off put them on the griddle and
use them to make perfectly round
pancakes yes or no yes right you're
right okay absolutely now we can get
back to some long form answer when I
used to work in McDonald's every once
awhile I knew I'd get the breakfast
shift yeah and in order to make the Egg
McMuffin you would have a miniature
priest like a priest collar collar but
this one would be for like a small like
if a cat was a man of the cloth yeah it
would be that size or a [ __ ] of the
cloth you say yeah
about three inches around and that's
what you'd crack your egg into it was a
template can I do tag take it was a form
pause here and boy ape a [ __ ] of the
cloth him real quick yeah I mean if you
want
Shh
at some point you have to stop this
don't you at some point and you're the
guy that worked at McDonald's and had a
[ __ ] caller yeah am I the bad guy for
once well I was 16 you worked at
McDonald's yes I did
when well as previously seen you think
I'm not listening but I retro here you
see yeah I asked myself and then I gave
the answer before you could even answer
right c-suite so you worked at McDonald
where no I don't think we had a
drive-thru this was the one in Studio
City on Ventura Boulevard and they still
don't have a drive-thru Wow one of the
few McDonald's with no drive-thru you've
got to get back to the future yes I do
and I would drive my DeLorean there and
I would get behind the griddle and I
would make Big Mac did you ever sweat on
the meat like it's inevitable what cuz
in those days you grilled over a grill
right it wasn't the microwave when you
were there it was always a huge griddle
bounce flat piece of steel did you ever
find it right for smelting oh yeah yeah
did you ever sweat by accident one of
the meat what would happen was is I was
forced to wear as my son was haha I was
forced to wear what is basically a a
brown rayon ghee you know back when they
had their stupid pants and stupid tops
and yeah hat and everything else well
one of the biggest beefs I used to get
into pardon the pun you know my manager
can is that he insisted when I worked
behind the grill that I wear this big
plastic smock but I'm already wearing
this rayon jumpsuit you know Oh who's
Brown rain pants it doesn't breathe very
well yeah I'm wearing the shoes and
they're kind of were they bell-bottom me
a little bit yeah they said no they said
no rubber soled shoes we're saying then
when people wearing ratty
tennis shoes yeah on the other hand I
didn't have any shoes that were dress
shoes except for my ninth grade
graduation shoes so I look like Fred
MacMurray standing there my feet are
killing me like and and he had you or
your graduations fused to McDonald why
everyday I wasn't going to buy
leather-soled shoes and shiny black like
yeah well these were brown but yeah
they're old school shoes alright
continue and I was standing there my
feet were killing me because I'd grown
two sizes since ninth the ninth grade
but I didn't have any shoes that were
rubber soled and I wasn't gonna buy
shoes expensive shoes just to work at
McDonald's for two dollars off
forty-two cents an hour and so my my
manager Ken would constantly insist that
I wear this big plastic smock while I
stood over the grill in the shoes with
the rayon outfit on and I remember sort
of thinking of myself I'm hot enough Ken
putting this big plastic smock over me
it's kill it's what boxers do to lose
weight they'll put a garbage bag on and
get on a bike and just yeah okay yeah
that's right so never doing that - yeah
yeah I was drying out over that thing
trying to make weight I was cutting
weight and did did your forehead drip
onto the griddle and yeah I was a sweaty
mess and I would say - I would say - Ken
like I'm pulling it up back here and
he'd say put the smock on and I would
always conveniently forget to put the
smock on oh he would always come and
remind me to put the suit if he ever
like towards the end of your shift
turn the the disco ball on and play a
slow song and you guys would have like
the final dance at the graduation like
we live that moment not every night like
what's that song with the the you had
the time of my life Righteous Brothers
like yeah you guys would slow dance and
you're shiny now ready at all for naming
the artists and the song I know within
three beats and there's a good job yeah
good job wow that's exciting
alright hey I wanted to see if you could
make up a new
ooh four-letter swear word mm-hmm and it
can't be the one that we already did
what was it Dingle don't want the metal
one no i-i've kind of tune it it tuned
out the whole metal yeah what's a
four-letter that we've never heard it's
brand-new well brand new I can tell you
this four letters in Jack and four
letters in whole um Jimmy and I in our
production company's called Jack Hoel
productions yeah we tried to invent a
swear word we could say on the radio
okay and Jack Hoel but that's what what
we ended up with that's four eight
letters well it's four and four can you
do a brand new one that the world the
planet Earth has never heard it before
can you come up with a four-letter one
right now and then I'm gonna need you to
you know use it in a sentence
uh-huh okay or letter mm-hmm so
douchenozzle is out that's a bit like I
would be a German four-letter swear word
okay we need English where lots can be
used at I don't know like it's gonna be
like clunk or cooling or you know
something forward lousy like can it
sound like it can sound like another
language right I would say speaking of
speaking of sort of German I would go
fits fair the z fi TZ yeah I like that
some shit's got some [ __ ] in yeah
and what I mean it just it just means
like bits
yeah fits yeah yeah it's like um you
could use it this way like you could say
I walked in my roommate and he was fits
in the bejesus out of his girl faster
there watch you know you stood and watch
I thought it was gonna end well I mean
if you didn't quite ly leave I might
have grabbed an e I don't know if I look
at the whole time you like your fits and
yeah Wow
okay see that was great I love it
what species of animals should
interbreed like I feel like a panda and
a zebra would make a good interbreeding
are there any other ones that would kind
of flat
yeah I I for me I like flight you know
and so for that you have you have the
barn owl barn owl yeah right right good
luck with this one yeah one of the most
little animals that is probably would be
that the coolest thing to see in flight
know that you'll never really have a
chance of seeing would be a manatee Oh
a manatee anavar towel manatee Wow
yeah that'd be hard to get off the
ground yeah but but imagine the majesty
of the manatee when it did take flight
for the first time maybe you could call
that a fat farmer no what would you call
that a fatty learn a barn of fat a fat
[ __ ] farmer no well what first off
Harlan what what is the manatee sound
like manatees are aquatic and they're
underwater so they're like like that
feel like there's a little bit of a
cop-out oh really okay well you wanted
like how would they talk under well what
I'm saying is is everything underwater
whether it's a manatee or you know
bluefin dolphin you're gonna make the
same underwater no a bluefin dolphin
under waters like oh I meant bluefin
tuna I meant bluefin - oh okay well
manatee and what would the tuna sound
like this tuna would be like okay we're
like a pulsing sound where's the manatee
has more of a it developed more of a
language because it's a mammal so it's
like boom boom boom boom
if you play that backwards it's actually
someone reciting the Second Amendment it
says Paul's a dead man yeah yeah so good
I like that barn owl and a manatee
mm-hmm splendid mm-hmm okay great well
let's go down at the end of uh at the
end of my podcast here I like to play a
little game called too soon or not too
soon okay it's for questions all right
and all you have to answer is
too soon or not too soon to play this
stupid game yeah student well mental
game okay ah here's the first question
you ready mm-hmm in 2016 should people
be allowed to put curly fries in their
pubes and pretend they are octopuses or
octopi too soon or not too soon not too
soon no al-imran it's too too soon oh
yeah okay well said Oh for one then yeah
so I got to run the table that go over
500 here yeah here's number two should
people with leprosy be allowed to give
you the finger meaning they can actually
pull their finger off and give it to you
hand it in too soon or not too soon too
soon
yeah correct yeah correct number three
should people who make sour patch kids
create an adult candy called sour patch
Clint's too soon I'm going too soon is
that Mike is that with a Z is that my
swear word sentence clothes not too soon
no no I don't gotta get this last one to
go 500 last last one here we go and then
we're gonna wrap up the show you've
heard of the dilly bar and the Dairy
Queen blizzard given the condition of
Bernie Sanders hair should his hair be a
new frozen delight at Dairy Queen called
the Bernie blast blowout frozen frost
[ __ ] Supreme too soon or not too soon
it's not too soon and I feel like you
could get head and shoulders to sponsor
that and this would be a layup right no
it's too soon and it's too you got one
yeah man I mean in a weird way it's like
doing a movie and just getting one star
like you'd rather almost just get zero
yeah all right well that's that's it for
this segment of the the podcast but do
you want to plug while we're here I was
like well plug their stuff man if people
like to see where I'm doing my shows
live or get a get my mug my mug is don't
do your best do my best
oh it's a lovely coffee mug
if t-shirts and podcasts and whatever
just go to Adam Carolla comm find out
everything because we're coming to you
yeah you pick up a nice mother future
yeah check out all out of stuff listen
to his podcast listen to all this Park
as I've you go on Adam hoo calm yeah see
movies they're everything there's all
women racing guys yes I saw that you
were gracious enough to invite me to the
premiere was amazing
I'm glad you came and I'm glad you enjoy
yeah yeah I loved it well go there and
go get one everybody okay cool awesome
yeah Adam Corolla ladies and gentlemen
uh my thanks to Adam my god what I what
a fun fun interview I mean Adam you just
can't stump them you can bring up any
topic that's why through a whole wide
range of questions Adam because you I
don't think I know a guy that that like
him that he just has answers for
everything and it's fascinating to hear
what he comes up with man and he doesn't
even blink like he just you could ask
him anything and he just rolls into some
kind of an answer it's it's quite a
unique gift and that's probably half the
reason why his his outstanding podcast
and all his other projects do so well
he's just he's got a lot of knowledge up
in that nugget and it was a pleasure to
have some laughs and and talk with the
Adam and by the way coming up soon if
you are a premium member of the Harlan
Highway podcast Adam and I coming up
very soon we are going to be doing my
premium podcast called let's have a
fight where me and Adam will be going
head-to-head with each other
and believe me Adam is not an easy guy
to fight with because he's he's very
intelligent and that's gonna be a real
battle so if you join my premium
membership it's probably coming up
within the next two weeks two to three
weeks Adam Carolla and Harlan Williams
let's have a fight and the premium
content is only 220
dollars a year to get that other podcast
and my life stand-up and all kinds of
bonus bonus things so there you go hope
you enjoyed hearing Adam and and let's
see what else they got here a stand-up
comedy coming up and next week
February 25th through the 28th I will be
in good Lord I will be in Scottsdale
Arizona at the house of comedy brand-new
comedy club it's only been open about a
year and a half it's a really wonderful
hip modern comedy club it's in beautiful
sunny Scottsdale Arizona go to Harlan
Williams comm and get all your ticket
information and then in March March 10th
to the 13th I'll be in the in Houston
Texas at the improv so please please
come out there and then moving over to
April it's the comedy party this is
gonna be an amazing if you live in Omaha
out there in Illinois in the Midwest a
Pauly Shore Tom Green Bobby Lee from
MADtv and myself are going to be doing
the comedy party it's three shows one
night only at each venue big fat
incredible theatres and you're getting
four amazing comics for the price of one
so go to my website Harlan Williams comm
and you can order your tickets before
they sell out cuz the comedy party is
gonna be a cool party also if you want
to leave me any phone messages if you
want to comment on the Adam Carolla
interview or anything else I say or do
on the podcast three to three seventy
thirty nine forty three thirty that's
three to three seventy thirty nine forty
three thirty that number isn't the
website Harlan Williams dot-com or you
can write to me at Harlan Williams comm
as well also check out our store at
Harlan Williams comm we have all kinds
of cool merchandise we can ship out to
you so that's it hope you enjoyed Adam
again my thing
to Adam Carolla tons of fun and as I
said watch out you premium members for
Adam Carolla on Harlan Williams let's
have a fight podcast coming up soon
thanks for being here and until next
time chicken xiaomin baby I'm pulling it
up back here and he'd say put the smock
on